[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous leurs du 7-8 journal sur
tv 60,18 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez tout de suite les titres de ce
jeudi 21 juin c'est le début de l'été le
jour le plus long de l'année elle date
traditionnelle de la fête de la musique
à saint quentin en yvelines plusieurs
concerts sont au programme
elle nous irons dans cette édition à
montigny le bretonneux et à plaisir ou
les pompiers seront les guest stars de
la soirée live des 78 a besoin de vous
l'association des diabétiques des
yvelines doit renouveler son bureau lors
de son assemblée générale samedi à
versailles
or les bénévoles et la nouvelle
génération manque pour prendre la relève
pour en parler est la future ex
présidente de l'association martine
morival est notre invité enfin sans
pilotes sont attendus pour la
compétition maurepas accueille ce
week-end le championnat de france de
course de voitures radiocommandées
elle nous suivrons la préparation du
club local de modélisme 3 milliards
l'île de france va investir 3 milliards
d'euros dans les quartiers populaires
d'ici à 2022 la présidente ait l'air de
la région valérie pécresse a dévoilé les
grandes lignes de son plan banlieue chez
nos confrères du parisien objectifs
fixés casser les ghettos
le conseil régional va financer la
construction de 100 logements innovants
et écologiques pour inciter les maires à
détruire les grands ensembles hlm 20000
prêts sous forme de micro crédits seront
accordées aux porteurs de projets enfin
à retenir également une majoration des
aides de 50% pour aider à l'installation
de la police municipale dans les
quartiers à la verrière le site de la
mgen est en pleine restructuration
quatre poules de spécialités médicales
sont en train de sortir de terre le site
accueillera notamment un secteur pour la
santé mentale pour les adultes et les
adolescents ainsi qu un ehpad les
patients seront te hébergés dans les
bâtiments et non plus dans des pavillons
les précisions avec ce sujet de nickel
et les minéraux
le chantier de la mgen de la verrière
avance ce jeudi 21 juin les quatre pôles
de spécialités médicales qui
comprendront notamment deux centres de
santé mentale et un ehpad commence à
prendre forme sur le site de 37 hectares
après un lancement des travaux à l'été
2016 tout
première partie de terrassement un gros
volume de terrassement à évacuer montage
des grues en avril 2017 et on est en
train de terminer la phase gros oeuvre
des bâtiments on a déjà des montées
trois des cinq grues nous reste deux
grues en place et les corps d'état
techniques et architecturaux ont bien
démarré pour rénover la zone plusieurs
pavillons construits dans les années 60
ont été rasés les derniers bâtiments
rez-de-chaussée seront également détruit
dans les prochains mois et les patients
déplacer dans des structures
ultramodernes
une fois que le bat les bâtiments seront
réceptionnés les patients qui sont dans
les divers battre pavillon existants
seront transférés dans les nouveaux
bâtiments et nous viendrons détruire et
finir les espaces verts le but ultime
étant que les patients aient un lieu de
vie j'irai à caractère non pas
hospitalier mais plutôt un caractère
deux résidences normal au total
l'établissement 9 comprendra 5 104 lits
95 de plus qu'avant la reconstruction
coût total de l'opération 80 millions
d'euros la livraison définitive est
prévue pour l'automne 2010 9 l actualité
du jour je vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'est la fête de la musique pour
célébrer le début de l'été alors pas
encore d'idée pour sortir ce soir est
bien à plusieurs villes de saint quentin
en yvelines propose des animations
premier exemple avec vous camille
lambert bonsoir vous êtes au centre
d'incendié et de secours de plaisir où
les pompiers sont en concert ce soir
et oui nous sommes avec romuald de
gauthier président de l'amicale des
sapeurs-pompiers de plaisir et pour une
fois ce n'est pas la ville mais bien les
pompiers qui vont mettre le feu ce soir
en musique
bonjour on y rit en effet pour la
première fois dans un centre de secours
des yvelines nous avons décidé d'ouvrir
les portes au public pour la fête de la
musique donc de 18 heures à minuit
nous aurons lorca départementale des
sports pj been qui va venir se produire
31 musiciens qui vont venir se produire
vers 20h30 pour nous accompagner dans ce
dans ce défi les pompiers mais pas
seulement parce que vous avez invité
également deux autres artistes y aura de
la pop et à l'électro avec un dj aussi
tout à fait donc nous avons un dj qui
est lui-même sa porte mais volontaire au
centre de secours donc qui facilite un
peu les choses qui va animer en début et
en fin de soirée et en promenant
deuxième partie du coup je dirais vers
19h30 nous aurons donc un chanteur de
trappes qui fait du pop africain malien
qui a des ce qui a bien voulu venir et
participer donc un effet de la musique
il est ravi de participer et surtout
dans un milieu qui ne me connaissaient
pas 1 5 million à un peu habituel pour
des concerts l'idée c'est un peu de
montrer que les pompiers on les appelle
quand on est en danger mais ça peut
aussi être festif
oui en effet
de plus en plus les centres de secours
ouvre sur leurs portes au public que ce
soit ce soir pour la fête de la musique
que ce soit pour le 13 et 14 juillet
prochains pour les différents bals des
sapeurs-pompiers rambouillet versailles
poissy et montigny pour pas les citer et
aussi pour toutes les journées portes
ouvertes que vous avez dans les centres
de secours des apports des des yvelines
voile bien s'amuser en tout cas ici ce
soir
merci beaucoup à romuald de goyet donc
les festivités ont déjà commencé ici et
vous êtes attendus nombreux jusqu'à
minuit la soirée camille merci à vous et
également à mélanie poker aux moyens
techniques avant de retrouver michael
medoro qui est lui à montigny le
bretonneux ce projet musical d'abord qui
a nécessité deux ans de travail de
découverte et de répétition ce week-end
lors castres demos des yvelines joue sur
la scène de la cité de la musique à
paris une centaine d'enfants le
composent nous les avons rencontrés la
semaine dernière lors de leur toute
dernière répétition c'était à
l'orangerie du château de versailles le
récit est signée mélanie poquet
[Musique]
le rondo dans les parcelles est devenu
une habitude pour eux ces enfants le
travail depuis près d'un an et demi avec
l'orchestré demos le dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale de la philharmonie de
paris et répète deux fois par semaine
ils apprennent la musique en collectif
avec des professeurs de la philharmonie
de paris dans leurs structures sociales
dans leur centre de loisirs dans le p r
e enfin chaque ville détermine une
structure sociale qui va porter le
projet ce sont des enfants qui a priori
n'aurait pas pousser les portes d'un
conservatoire n'aurait pas pratiquer la
musique classique et donc le projet
demos ses valeurs c'est d'aller vers la
démocratisation culturelle et l'accès à
une forme de culture en l'occurrence la
culture classique depuis novembre 2016
ils sont entourés de musiciens
professionnels d'un chef d'orchestre de
la philharmonie et d'encadrants nous on
est là pour leur apprendre la technicité
de l'instrument qu'ils ont choisi et
également de les ouvrir et de leur père
écouté beaucoup de styles de musique
différents des notions de formation
musicale des comptes dans leur coeur
striby mois une centaine d'enfants dont
des very roi des trappistes et des
plaisirs oit j'avais un peu de mal à
jouer
après après je suis en retrait mais je
me suis entraîné j'ai pas lâcher ça va
il ya les professeurs qui nous aide si
on n'arrive pas et dans les cours
particuliers à plaisir il y a
un professeur du violon qui m'agace et
la chine premiers de ma famille j'ai
donc est la fierté d'avoir moi je suis
très heureuse de jouer de la musique je
me dis que j'ai de la chance de pouvoir
faire ça après des concerts dans les
yvelines leur dernier rendez vous est à
paris à la cité de la musique
il vous emmène en voyage avec à 1500
secunia leaf une musique traditionnelle
gréco turque
allez direction à présent le parvis du
muy m'aide à montigny-le-bretonneux vous
l'entendez sur ce plateau miquel et demi
d'euros et sur place bonsoir la fête de
la musique et qui va battre son plein ce
soir mickaël sur ce parvis c'est à
partir de 19h oui oui grégory l'ambiance
monte petit à petit qu'ils france info à
montigny-le-bretonneux vous attendez
juste derrière moi les valence ils sont
en train de s'effectuer à mes côtés pour
parler de cette soirée antoine boesch le
directeur du pôle théâtre musique à
montigny-le-bretonneux antoine ce qui va
se passer concrètement alors ce soir
bien c'est la fête de la musique donc on
va avoir dans un premier temps le bagad
de saint quentin introduction qui va se
promener un peu dans les tons les rues
du centre commercial on aura une petite
petite introduction une petite
demi-heure de zumba et après le groupe
que vous voyez derrière vous smart
musique quitte un groupe de reprises pop
rock qui va proposer à un public
familial
comme l'année dernière voilà une fête de
la musique
plein phare le style pop rock c'est
vraiment ce qui plaît ici avanthier
bretonneux oui oui l'année dernier
le public était vraiment content
d'entendre des grands standards ce soit
en rock que ce soit en fun comme on
chanson et c'est pour ça qu'on a
renouvelé cette édition de la fête de la
musique vous attendez combien de
personnes en général sur une soirée
comme celle là alors l'année dernière
entre 500 et 1000 personnes on a des
personnes qui sont là devant la scène
et puis on a tout autour sur les
terrasses des restaurants aussi beaucoup
de gens qui sont là pour pas pour passer
un dîner en musique
et voilà c'est tout le monde est là pour
cette grande fête
qu'est ce que vous attendez d'un groupe
comme celui là celui qui est derrière
nous c'est de proposer au public de la
musique que l'on connaisse et de pouvoir
passer un moment festif et de danser et
de chanter
voilà sur cette fête de la musique qui
est un événement populaire par
excellence
quand vous avez fait pour les recruter
j'avais passé un casting non tout
simplement on a on avait un groupe
l'année dernière deux reprises et on a
on a fureté un peu on s'est renseigné et
ont été joués sur ce groupe tient un
groupe de grande qualité
ce soir à quel moment c'est vrai que la
soirée réussie ici avanthier moteur ben
on aura vers 21h30 22h au plein de la
fête de la musique
après le match voilà les gens qui seront
là pour bas pour passer comme je disais
un monde un monde fait ça se termine
vers 23 heures à 3 heures pas plus on
sait jamais 23h et plus si affinités
voilà en fonction des rappels du public
par rapport à ce groupe merci beaucoup
antoine vous l'aurez compris grégory
c'est ici qu'il y aura l'ambiance ce
soir pour la fête de la musique mais je
vous invite à me rejoindre dans quelques
instants après jour la neige vers la
michael merci
vous étiez sur place avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et si vous n'êtes pas
habitants de plaisir ni de montigny le
bretonneux pour connaître le programme
de la fête de la musique dans votre
ville je vous invite à vous rendre sur
le site internet de vos communes
toujours à montigny le bretonneux tous
les voyants sont au vert pour promo paul
hier à la mi-journée la pépinière
présentait à ses résultats
d'exploitation pour 2010 est un chiffre
d'affaires en hausse un taux de
remplissage à 80 1% pour une centaine
d'entreprises adhérentes promo paul qui
se fixe pour objectif d'avoir zéro euro
de dette l'an prochain en 2014 cette
dette s'élevait à 1,8 million d'euros
est la structure un temps au bord de la
faillite vient d'ailleurs de remporter
son procès à la cour d'appel de
versailles contre l'ancienne direction
elle est reconnue coupable de mauvaise
gestion il a fallu procéder à une
refonte totale de la société écouter son
président au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude l'idée depuis le départ c'est
qu'on puisse avoir une structure qui ne
vivent plus sous perfusion d'argent
public et qui effectivement puisse être
autonome sur le plan financier
même excédentaire et on y est 2017 nous
avons fait notre troisième exercice
excédentaire après sept années de pertes
consécutives depuis depuis 2009 devant
inverser cette tendance là grâce à ce
travail de gestion
la réalité c'est que on l'a fait surtout
sans un euro d'argent public c'était
important que ce ne soit pas le
contribuable qui paye les erreurs de
gestion les erreurs à la fois morale et
en même temps financières qui ont été
prises par la précédente direction donc
nous avons fait ce travail là
aujourd'hui
les autonomes et donc elle peut
effectivement sans solliciter à nouveau
le de l'argent public continue de
fonctionner cette année
promo paul prévoit de rénover ses locaux
les travaux commenceront à cet été elle
était justement c'est une période idéale
pour faire un stage à l'étranger dans le
cadre du programme erasmus la maison de
l'europe des yvelines envoie chaque
année une vingtaine de jeunes de mission
locale dans un pays européen pour une
expérience professionnelle de trois mois
cette semaine à saint germain en laye
onze jeunes sur le retour ont ainsi reçu
leur europass mobilité un diplôme
délivré par la commission européenne qui
valide les compétences acquises lors de
ces stages
une expérience enrichissante pour la
suite de leur parcours
c'est pour leur donner l'occasion
d'aller exercer un métier dans un autre
pays de voir la culture de voir comment
ça se passe ailleurs
professionnellement parlant ça m'a
apporté un gros plus à mettre sur mon cv
notamment au niveau linguistique la
chance de pouvoir partir plus facilement
et accessoirement c'est un gros plus
professionnel un point de vue différent
sur le travail le fait de travailler
dans une autre langue et devoir
m'adapter
ça c'est une faculté d'adaptation je
pense principalement et si vous aussi
vous êtes intéressé par la perspective
de partir faire un stage à l'étranger
contacter la maison de l'europe des
yvelines martin morival est avec nous
bonsoir vous êtes la présidente de l'afd
78 l'association des diabétiques des
yvelines enfin alors plus pour longtemps
puisque votre association se réunit en
assemblée générale ce samedi 7 à partir
de 14h30 à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles
une assemblée où vous ne vous
représenterez pas la tête de
l'association et où vous allez
renouvelez votre bureau c'est une page
qui se tourne pour l'afd 78 oui oui tout
à fait je
pour ma part je suis dans cette
association depuis de nombreuses années
pour des raisons tout à fait
personnelles et jeu après qu elles
toutes ces années passées à travailler
avec un bureau et des collègues très
motivés dans lesquelles tout le monde a
su s'investir pendant toutes ces années
il est temps il est temps de passer la
main en effet de passer le flambeau
malheureusement actuellement nous avons
de grosses difficultés à trouver des
bénévoles
aujourd'hui le
le milieu associatif ce n'est pas
uniquement notre association un qui est
en manque de bénévoles
je pense que c'est l'ensemble du milieu
associatif qui souffrent de cette
pénurie de bénévoles
les causes sont plus ou moins connus
maintenant j'espère à travers ses
passages dans votre émission pouvoir
fédérer de futurs bénévoles et alors on
va parler justement de ce manque de
bénévoles dans un instant si vauxrot
fait un bilan des années que vous avez
passées à la tête de cette association
quel bilan vous tirer un bilan très
positif c'est une association qui est
très sollicitée n'oublions pas que le
diabète aujourd'hui c'est quand même 4
millions de personnes en france qui sont
touchés par cette maladie
c'est entre cinq cent mille et 800 me
qui s'ignore c'est quotidiennement 400
personnes par jour qui sont dépistés à
travers cette pathologie qui devient un
enjeu de santé publique
et ça je pense que le l'état et tous les
toutous les toutes les personnes
concernées le le met bien en avant
il faut travailler continuer à
travailler même si beaucoup de travail
est déjà fait nous nous sommes
énormément sollicités le problème étant
que par manque de bénévoles nous
pourrons pu répondre à la demande et
cette année a été une année charnière
justement dans des prises de décisions
qui aujourd'hui m'amène à quitter cette
présidence
donc nous avons un différentes actions 1
que ce soit à travers des ateliers des
acquittements très sollicités qui se
porte bien avec des finances tout à fait
correct nous avons également des
commandes hirèche des adhérents à nous
avons actuellement plus d'une centaine
d'adhérents mais pour faire fonctionner
cette association malheureusement il
nous faut de la main d'oeuvre et là
c'est le problème en quad et des bonnes
volontés samedi
ce cas de figure s'il se présente si
vous n'arrivez pas à renouveler votre
bureau qu'elle risque finalement il y à
t'il pour l'afd 78 me suis rapproché
bien évidemment de notre fédération 1
qui dans les bureaux sont sur paris je
pense que nous ne sommes pas la seule
association d'aef de la vie des êtres en
souffrance par manque de bénévoles
il y à une réflexion qui à mon sens se
met en place et je l'espère puisque à
partir de samedi en effet si personne ne
reprend le flambeau là je remets les
pleins pouvoirs entre les mains de la
fédération et nous pourrons pas donné
suite
dans tous les cas je trouve cela
regrettable sachant qu'aujourd'hui notre
mission nos missions principales qui
sont prévenir et d'informer surtout de
défendre l'accès à des soins de qualité
pour tous les patients et lutter contre
les discriminations liées à la maladie
cette maladie est en augmentation
perpétuelle c'est ce diabète de type 2
aujourd'hui on est en avance de diabète
c'est le diabète de type 2 aujourd'hui
qui tricotent libre et cela continuera à
progresser
aujourd'hui nous mettons en avant elle
et a su le faire à travers les maladies
cardiovasculaires et toute la prévention
qui est mis en place autour de ça le
diabète fait partie d'un facteur de
risque et pour ce faire il faut
continuer à se battre faire de la
prévention et informer les personnes les
accompagnent quotidiennement explique
avec une population qui est de plus en
plus sédentaire il ya aussi peut-être un
problème au niveau de l'alimentation la
malbouffe qui aussi peut expliquer cette
expansion du diabète la sédentarité la
malbouffe comme vous dites
aujourd'hui tout le monde court
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est la priorité c'est ben c'est
de se lever le matin d'aller travailler
de rentrée le me dit souvent ce serait
un sandwich etc
nous sommes là justement pour prévenir
informer nous avons même qui est
éthicienne à disposition etc
donc c'est pour vous dire que
l'association est vraiment bien ancrée
dans les yvelines puisque notre nos
bureaux en a qui se trouve un institut
de la promotion de la santé à trappes
avec d'autres associations donc c'est
pour vous dire qu'il ya quand même
énormément de choses qui sont faites au
tour et nous sommes très sollicités
quotidiennement toute personne qui est
admise à l'hôpital pour un dépistage de
diabète ressort au bout d'un certain
temps et avec un certain nombre de
questions et nous sommes là pour y
répondre le tessin d'information goudé
est tout à l'heure et du coup il est
vrai que ben votre téléphone sonne
relativement souvent pour apporter
rassurer accompagné proposé peut-être
voilà une diététicienne etc
il y a énormément de travail c'est très
intéressant
je suis dedans avec toujours cette même
conviction j'ai quand même également
beaucoup de regrets à la quitter
mais voilà c'est également d'autres
projets on comprend dans vos propos
aujourd'hui c'est primordial que cette
association existe dans le département
qu'elle continue d'exister dans ce
département elle doit continuer à
exister
c'est je dirais que si de bonnes âmes
ont envie vraiment de s'investir en tous
les cas moi je les attends et mme alors
je les recevrai vraiment de manière
correcte cinq dealers de nos trajets
pour leur présenter et nos missions nos
valeurs qui sont l'entrée de la
solidarité l'engagement et ça ça doit
rester de toute façon des valeurs pour
pour l'ensemble des associations et pour
ce bénévolat et qui a tendance
malheureusement à disparaître
c'est une tendance générale pour le
milieu associatif on a compris votre
appel si on doit rappeler les actions
concrètes qui seront mises en place sur
sur le territoire quelles sont elles
alors nous sommes sollicités par les
différentes communes au fond personne
faisant partie justement de la ds qui y
assurer communauté avec toutes ces
villes qui nous sollicitent à travers
des missions quotidiennes mais également
dans des ateliers des actions de
dépistage
quand on parle de dépistage ça va être
les dépistages sous forme de deux
questionnaires mais également des
pistaches glycémique elles ont fait la
petite goutte de sang pour savoir nous
ne sommes pas là pour poser un
diagnostic ou autre attention nous
restons avant tout d une association qui
sommes là pour faire du dépistage de la
prévention nous restons l'écoutent voilà
et c'est vraiment de la prévention
primaire pour nous nous n'allons pas au
delà et quand il y à un risque ou autre
on oriente immédiatement sur les
professionnels de santé vous parliez
d'ateliers ça peut être par exemple des
ateliers nutritionnels tout à fait alors
justement nous avons fait même avec la
ceppm sur versailles où nous avions
organisé tout un après midi où nous
avions donc un une personne donc
diabétiques faisant partie du bureau qui
avaient été formés par la fédération à
l'éducation thérapeutique est dû de ce
fait les personnes qui venaient donc
avait on leur proposer un dépistage on
leur proposait de rencontrer notre
diététicienne mais également de pouvoir
aller voir notre personne qui était
spécialisée dans l'éducation
thérapeutique
donc c'est tout un un petit réseau mis
en interne qui permet à chacun de se
retrouver et de mieux comprendre en fait
ce qui lui arrive à travers le diabète
juste avant de vous laisser martine
aubry morival quel message vous
souhaitez passer aux gens qui nous
regardent
si vous avez de la disponibilité du
temps accordé
l association est ouverte à tous moi je
ne suis pas diabétique je suis maman
d'un enfant diabétique et tout se passe
très bien on demande un petit peu de
temps pour s'investir et y croire croire
en ce que l'on fait tous les jours
partir du principe que nous sommes là
pour aider accompagner prévenir et ça
c'est vraiment le plus important mais il
faut de la disponibilité oui et pour
vous contacter en tout cas il ya le site
internet de l'efs des 78 qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci à martin hameau
rival d'avoir été avec nous aux
présidentes futur ex présidente de cette
association l'afd 78 elle devait fermer
définitivement ses portes en juillet
pour des raisons budgétaires à
versailles la piscine de satory restera
finalement ouverte la ville a pu trouver
une solution avec le ministère de
l'intérieur qui est propriétaire des
lieux une bonne nouvelle pour les
militaires mais aussi pour les clubs et
associations qui utilisent l'équipement
camille lambert et patrick jacques de
dixmude environ 200 personnes
s'entraînent ici chaque jour la piscine
de satory situé dans le quartier
militaire de versailles vient d'être
sauvée d'une fermeture définitive le
mystère l'intérêt nous avait dit qu'il
fermerait définitivement la piscine pour
des raisons d'économies budgétaires à
partir du 1er juillet 2018
donc pour nous c'était une vraie
préoccupation ce que ces piscines et est
nécessaire non seulement pour le
quartier de satory mais aussi pour les
activités des clubs et notamment le
grand club de versailles de natation le
snd versailles a donc négocié cette
décision et a pu trouver une solution la
commune ne pouvant assumer
financièrement le rachat de la structure
le ministère de l'intérieur toujours
propriétaire lui a confié la gestion des
dieux et un transfert de gestion et donc
ensuite la ville versailles va lancer
une opération dite d'autorisation
occupation temporaire ce qu'on appelle
une aute des structures juridiques qui
permet de confier à un gestionnaire on
verra lequel le soin de faire marcher la
piscine un contrat pour cinq ans
renouvelables mais avec la possibilité
d'arrêter à tout moment des deux côtés
la ville investit c'est environ 120
milles euros par an pour la location de
lignes d'eau son budget restera le même
la piscine utilisé essentiellement par
les militaires associations et scolaire
ne sera pas ouverte au public pour
refermer ce journal vous allez vivre ce
week-end une course automobile en
miniature le modélisme maurepas club
accueille le championnat de france de
course de voitures radiocommandées plus
de 100 pilotes sont attendus et le club
se prépare à les recevoir patrick
jacques de dixmude et camille lambert
sont allés à la rencontre des membres
elle a participé à sa finale et donc il
va falloir tout démonter tout vérifié
puisque on est vraiment sur des voitures
de compétition qui sont assez sensibles
à l'usure s'il s'agit d'un modèle réduit
hors de question de prendre cette
voiture radiocommandée pour un jouet
donc là j'ai pas fais nettoyage complet
du moteur habituellement on démonte tout
on nettoie tout dans des produits exprès
et à des pneus niveau d'huile embrayage
autant de paramètres à vérifier avant de
retourner sur le circuit christophe est
un habitué cela fait trente ans qu'il
participe à des compétitions
je suis plutôt dans les vétérans à dire
je fais encore des compétitions
nationales
dans l'autre catégorie que j'ai pratiqué
pendant pas mal d'années j'étais au
niveau championnat de france élite et
championnats d'europe puisque j'ai fait
un podium de championnat d'europe donc
une troisième place à brest et puis
l'année d'avant j'avais fait 4e
aujourd'hui responsable de la section
tout terrain ou modélisme morta club il
est passé côté organisation parce qu'on
arrive avec pas mal de vitesse on se
retrouve mal placé pour la table
américaine qui est juste derrière
l'association accueille des 23 et 24
juin une manche championnat de france à
quelques jours de la rencontre
il s'assure du bon état du terrain
[Musique]
j'ai fait quelques tours de circuit pour
valider les travaux qu'on a pu réaliser
pour préparer ses prochains championnats
de france donc l'objectif c'était de
valider que les boss sauter correctement
que les raccords entre les différents
revêtements du circuit ne posait pas de
problème est que le traitement qu'on a
fait sur la piste va aussi va donner
entière satisfaction puisque a beaucoup
de risques parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'endroits on peut se reposer
et vraiment bien peu de contracter terre
bois avait bossé ligne droite
un terrain varié de deux mètres carrés
plus de 100 pilotes s'élanceront sur le
circuit
c'est la fin de ce journal les
reportages sont à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
soixante dix huit dans un instant
retrouver et nicolas kirilow vide c'est
le 7-8 débat une question avec ses
invités fusions de communes
un mariage forcé c'est à suivre belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]